good morning believe nation today's
message is be driven over to you jamie
foxx I had to learn drive that's why I
have my managers to teach me drive or to
you know push me because you can relax
you can say oh I could do that or I
could do that but are you gonna be there
present I know this person this person
who calls me up man did you see what
Denzel did in that movie man that was
you like he said I could have and maybe
he could have but he doesn't have the
drive the Denzel and so therefore if you
don't have a drive then you never you
you quit cultivating your talent because
once you rest and once you say it's over
I've gotten to the mountaintop then your
talent starts to dwindle too that's why
the minute the war season was over I was
at Wet Willie's in Miami doing jokes for
people just on the street I was like
what just to see what would work you
know jokes either about the Oscars are
jokes about whatever and then you go to
Atlanta and work on your jokes there so
that hustle what I call hustle it's very
important because at some point you're
gonna be able to pull the hustle back
just a little bit and then you pick your
spots the time right now is I hustle to
set things up so that in the future
you're able to cut back just a little
bit and just pick your spots for me a
lot of this still comes down to
environment I think the the environment
that you're in matters the people around
you matters again what you're reading
what your watch really matters because I
think too many people are comfortable
where they are and their environment
keeps them where they are and you don't
have people pushing you to get better
pushing you to drive faster pushing you
to go a little bit harder I think a lot
of people are just comfortable being the
big fish in a small pond instead of
jumping to a bigger pond and being that
small fish trying to get better I think
a lot of people are in a race you know
they're in a hundred meter race and
they're racing against five-year-olds
and so they win all the time and when
you are winning all the time in that
small race it's easy to just stay there
as he look at me I'm great look at all
the great stuff I'm doing I don't need
to work harder I don't need to push
faster I'm already winning everything
and for a lot of people that's that's
where they are
you know that's where I was where I was
doing more than the people around me
where anytime we'd have get-togethers
coffees meetings or whatever was always
only praise like ah look at this great
stuff that you're doing and it's easy
for me to sit back and say yeah look
look at all this great stuff in there
and take my foot off the gas where I
want to play in a bigger game I want to
race against Usain Bolt I want to race
against people who are faster than me
and I may lose right I may lose I'm
gonna lose racing against Usain Bolt I'm
gonna lose against people who are faster
than me but my time will be faster my
time racing against a five-year-old
versus my time racing against sprinters
I may lose that race but my time will be
faster so I'm getting better I'm pushing
harder and so that's what you need for
yourself you want to be driven you want
to do something bigger you want to push
more you need to have people around you
who are better than you it's why I
started the top ten series in the mentor
me series to learn from people to be
around them we've done a lot more than
us so I look at my life and while I'm
grateful for everything that's happened
and everything that has been
accomplished
I still realize that it's nothing
compared to what all these other people
are doing it's not looking at those
people and say well I suck I can't go
out and do that it's inspiration is like
I want to I can push harder I'm not
pushing hard enough right now I can do
more I'm just gonna sit back and keep
racing five-year-olds I want to go off
and play a bigger game I want to jump to
that bigger pool and so if you're
worried that you're not driven enough
that you're not following through in
your goals enough that you don't have
big enough goals that you don't believe
in yourself enough look at your
environment look at your habits look at
your routine look at the people around
you look at what you're consuming on a
consistent daily basis you need to be
around people and things that push you
to do more to believe in yourself more
to dream bigger dreams to believe that
those are possible to grow and chase to
wake up and work and hustle and drive
for yourself for your family for your
community for the world it's important
so if you're on the lazy side
chances are you have an environment
around you that supports laziness change
your environment so changing your life
so the question today today is do you
have an environment that supports you
and accomplishing your big dreams or not
leaving the comments below I'm gonna
join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout to aurora by lagdi
thank you so much for picking up a cup
of my book it really really really means
a lot to me and I hope it helps you find
your one word so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of inter